start
good morning everyone so for today's
tutorial talk
it's a pleasure to have ahmed uh alawi
um
who's an assistant professor in the
department of statistics and data
science at cornell university
and he's going to talk about
methods from statistical physics
thank you
um
yeah thank you to the organizer for
organizing this and it's always really
nice to go back to berkeley i did my
grad school here and i have found
memories being in this audience um
yeah so i was asked to give a tutorial
about methods from statistical physics
and i didn't know what to talk about and
now that i spend a few days with you
guys now i know that better what could
be interesting to this audience
so i'll be focusing as here the second
bullet says on statistical inference so
um the main
goal here is to introduce the notions
that are mostly used and the techniques
that are mostly used
in stat phase to address this type of
questions that are relevant to
statistical inference
and
i'll be proceeding with very specific
models i'm not going to claim any
generality in this field it is almost
useless to try to formulate a general
theory so i'll just be considering very
specific models and i'll be studying
them
and
the tools that are used are
generalizable you just have to change
them depending on the the kind of models
that you're looking at but the main
ideas are still the same
okay so perhaps i should give an outline
for this first lecture
i'll be introducing gibbs measures
and so these are posterior measures
because i'll only be looking at
statistical inference these are really
posterior measures
of statistical models
i'll introduce the free energy the
partition function look at the
derivatives of those and also introduce
perhaps
one model where we can see a phase
transition
um
and i'll talk
about the gaussian additive model this
is the model that we're going to be
mostly looking at
and perhaps
depending on where we end i'll talk
about the spiked
matrix model
which is a special special case of the
gaussian additive model
okay so let me start jumping right in um
so let's start in one dimension
i'm going to start with the gaussian
additive model and then i'll define all
of these things
within the this gaussian added model
let me just write gamm
instead of keeping
so here we have a signal signal
random variable that is drawn from some
prior p0 this is in r so this then is
just a real number
and we're going to draw a gaussian that
is independent
from x0 and then we're going to observe
a number y
that could be written as square lambda
times x0 plus c
right where lambda is a fixed constant
so you observe y and you would like to
understand what's going on with x0 right
so i can try to look at the distribution
so what is first of all what is the
density
of line given x0
so this is just a gaussian density
because this is gaussian right so
you get
right so that's the density
now if you use the bayes rule i'll try
to get the posterior measure of x zero
given y
right
so there's a normalization constant that
i'm going to call z so if you use the
base the base rule you get
exponential the same thing
and if i start removing the things that
don't matter so here i only care about
x0 so the y is a constant it's going to
go away what's going to matter is the
square of this and the cross products
right so
there's a plus here i get
square root lambda y x 0 minus lambda
over 2
x 0 squared the prior is
dp 0 of x 0 right
now z is whatever
normalizing constant will make this
integrate to one right
so more explicitly z is
the integral of that
okay so this is called the partition
function of the model this is a gibbs
measure
the posterior measure in particular and
here we have a very specific function in
the exponential which is given by this
model just follows from from the
definition of this model but you could
have any function here so perhaps call
it f of x
right
x0
so this is called the hamiltonian this
is called the partition function
and you may notice here that's this
hamiltonian depends on y which is a
random variable right so
this whole measure is itself random
right
and this partition function is itself
random
now if i take the logarithm of z and
take an expectation in front
i'm going to call that f of lambda
function of lambda and y to make things
explicit
right so here i'm taking an expectation
over y so this is a deterministic
function of lambda that's called the
free energy right
are there any questions so far yeah
lambda is
a signal to noise ratio let's say so
it's just a constant that multiplies the
signal x0 if it's big then estimation or
you know the model gives you a lot of
information about x0 what x0 is but if
lambda is small then it doesn't give you
much information it's just like a tunein
parameter
yeah
right
and just for notation i will whenever i
integrate or defense with respect to x0
i'm just gonna drop the
not subscript
okay
to distinguish it
from the actual x0 that enters the
definition of y so okay
this is all fine right
whenever i integrate with respect to x
i'll just write x
okay
uh so is this partition the free energy
is now just depending on this partition
function is this like
so you lose some dependence on the uh on
like that distribution you're right up
there right because now it's only
dependent on this integral
over that distribution so this thing a
priori has all the information most of
the information you need to reconstructs
the behavior here
so yeah so good question this function
is you can think of it as some kind of
cumulative generating function so you
know the moment generating function the
logarithm of that it's the cumulative
function and it contains a lot of the
information you would like to understand
about this posterior measure so in
principle you don't lose anything
other questions
okay so
another um object here is the posterior
mean so if i look at the mean vector of
this uh of this posterior measure
let me call it m hats
and m hat will depend on y right so
that's just
the expectation of x given y right
and if you're a bayesian and you would
like to minimize the mean squared error
so i give you y and i asked you to
compute an estimate of x and you're
doing just minimum minimum mean square
that you're trying to minimize the mean
squared error then this is the minimizer
right so if you look at the mmsc
which is
minimum over all
estimators theta hats
of the square
distance between x0
and data how to fly right
so the minimizer
minimizer is just the
this and then this becomes
the expectation
right
and notice that this also only depends
on lambda
so i want to now introduce something
that is very specific to statistical
models
which is called uh
the bayes rule or sometimes it's also
called the nishimari property
the name comes from a different um
interpretation it didn't they didn't
people did not realize it was the base
rule when they discovered this
so the experiment is as follows
so generate x0 like i said here
from p0 then
generate y
according to that model
now draw
x1 x2
dot dot xn
iid
from the posterior
right
given y
now i want to understand the following
expectation
i have done
so look at the expectation of a function
phi of x1 x2 dot dot y
and let's write x0 before y
xn
zero and y
right
so if i condition on y
d is our independence
it's all 10 given y
right
so these guys only depend on y when you
condition on them they're independent
and they're fixed the only thing that is
random now is x0 but the distribution of
x0 given y
is
x0 given y has the same distribution as
any of these right
so i can also write x1 x2
okay let me write it
x and x0 y that's also as i said
the expectation of x 1 x 2 dot dot x n
x n plus 1
y
right this is a tool
so this is just by the bayes rule right
so
this planted signal
acts as another draw from the posterior
when you look at averages of this form
right
in particular if you just look at
in particular if you look at x1
x2
so this this is a draw these are two uh
draws from the posterior and prob in
distribution it's the same thing as
looking at x0 x1
so this is a fundamental property for
statistical models
in this in this theory
[Music]
we'll see that's going to be useful
in some of the computations we're going
to do
right so now that we've defined all of
this
i can look at
derivatives of the free energy
uh perhaps another lemma that i'm going
to use
so lemma
this is gaussian integration by parts
that's going to be useful and i'm going
to say
you know that if you have a gaussian
random variable and you look at the
expectation of z times f of z or z
where f is a differentiable function
such that this expectation makes sense
say that f has
almost at most polynomial growth
then this is also the same thing as
the expectation of f prime right so this
is just by integration by parts
now let me look at the derivatives of
f
these are fundamental objects
if i look at the first derivative
so that's
the derivative of this thing so you see
here z depends on y
uh z depends on lambda excuse me also on
y of course
and
but y also depends on lambda so i would
have to expand this
expression in here so that i get a full
dependence on lambda right
so let me write that so the expectation
here will be over x0 and z
logarithm
and then if i expand the expression of y
i get square root
lambda z x plus lambda x zero x
minus lambda
s
right and now you see why i removed the
knots from from this from this
expression is that now i have an x zero
on x
so if i take a derivative
so i guess it's a logarithm so i got a
ratio
uh i didn't introduce this okay i'll
introduce that
if i take a derivative i get what i get
x
plus x0 x minus x squared over 2.
exponential f
this is f
over exponential f
okay
now i'm going to keep this term as it is
i'll keep this term as it is and i'm
going to look at this term
this term has a gaussian in it
so i'll pull that gaussian outside and
i'm going to use this lemma
so
and okay so to simplify notation here
instead of keep writing ratios like this
i'll define the gibbs average
which will be
that
okay so this is called the gibbs average
now if i look at that first term so i
have 1 over 2 squared lambda
expectation z
x
so this is what that is in this notation
so z can be taken outside
here
and this whole function is a function of
z
so this is
one over two square lambda
expectation d over d z
of this ten
by dot
lambda so now if you take a derivative
of this
thin so i have to differentiate upstairs
and downstairs
when you differentiate with respect to z
then you have a square lambda x that
falls off
so the square lambda will go the square
with lambda
i get one half
but then when the x falls off in the
numerator i guess you get an x squared
by the way let me know if
you can go down with the camera
and then if i differentiate the
denominator i get an
this times the same thing which is
this
right this is just the rule right stop
me if you don't understand the
computation
okay so now what is the derivative
yes correct
that's correct
that's correct
so what is f prime
i dealt with this term it gives me this
good then i have these two terms so i
have plus expectations outside of course
everything is an expectation
i have this term which is x zero x
and then i have this term
plus one half
right
so this one will go away with this one
and i have this and that right
so i have
0x minus one-half
these two things are equal
right
so this is just half of whether whether
any any of those two but let me just
write it like this
so the derivative of the free energy
will give you a quantity that's so what
is again let me write this a bit more
explicitly this gives this gives average
is the posterior mean as you know
observed
right
and this is the same thing as that
the derivative will tell you information
about the magnitude of the or the second
moment of the
the posterior mean
and if i try to do this computation in
more than one dimension so everything
here is one dimensional but you can look
at a model in n dimensions right so a
vector y and a vector z and a vector x
zero here you can do the same
computation except you have inner
products everywhere this is a norm inner
products everything works out and this
becomes a two norm
now if i look at the second derivative i
will not go through the computation
again
perhaps this is an exercise
so i try to do the same computation a
bit more involved and has more terms in
it
but then what you would get is the
expectation of the covariance or the
variance i mean one dimension
the variance
of x given y
squared perhaps it is squared
yes
right so the same type of computation
will give you this
and if i was in more than one dimension
the variance becomes covariance
and then so since that's a matrix you
take the probinus norm
now these computations are not difficult
to do but they're they're fundamental
like
most of the why you want to compute free
energy is like you can ask why do we
care about free energies is precisely
because you can compute this quantity in
this quantity
so these are the first two cumulants
right
so perhaps let me introduce
one other object which is called the
mutual information
i'm gonna have to start going a bit
faster at some point
between two random variables x and y
as um
probably know this so this is the kl
divergence between the
joint distribution and the products of
the marginals
so if i apply this to my problem so if
this is x0 and this is y
what do i get i get the expectation so
i'm just writing the definition of kl
fp
xy
the x
dpy right
and this is expectation logarithm
so now let me look at decompose this as
a given
x x given y excuse me
times p of y right so p of y goes away
with p of y
and p x is just p0 right and then i have
an x and a y here
so i just erased what this is it was in
one of the boards here
if you take
the density of the posterior with
respect to the
to the prior you get the exponential f
over z right
exponential let me just write after that
i'm gonna need the expression actually
right over z
now okay so you do the computation so
the log will go the exponential you
compute the expectation of this 10
and you will get
one half the expectation of x squared
minus expectation log z that's f
right so you just get the second moment
half of the second moment
minus the free energy so the mutual
information and free energy are the same
thing
right
and this gives you an information what
is the if i observe why how much
information do i have about x0
so now that we've computed the
derivative of f
the derivative of i think there should
be a lambda somewhere
this would be a lambda here
zero
lambda over two is that correct slant
over two
right
so if i take a derivative with respect
to lambda of this quantity i get one
half this minus the derivative we
computed the derivative
right
minus the derivative
is this
so do you recognize this expression
perhaps with uh
you try to
expand the squares of something you get
this
the mmsc
so we could have the mmc
so this is a famous relation in
information theory it's called the imse
theorem right
so this is a simple derivation of the
immense theorem
so you have these relationships if you
can compute the mutual information or
the free energy you can compute the mmsc
you can compute this quantity which are
basically the same thing so that's one
of the main interests of doing this
right
so computing
computing f
is the same thing as computing
mmsc through a derivative right so if
you take a derivative you get that
and a lot of the proofs in this area are
of the form if you want to compute f you
try to compute the analysis you're going
to have to come up with the optimal
estimator
and then integrate that with respect to
lambda you'll get a function of you get
an expression of f and vice versa if you
want to compute the msc you compute this
you get a limiting expression you take a
derivative stretch
okay
so now we're going to see a phase
transition
so you see here i did everything in one
dimension everything's univariance
there's no possible phase transition
that could happen you're in one
dimension there's nothing that could
happen
but now i'm going to look at a
multi-dimensional problem
and it's a simple one it's the gaussian
mean location problem
[Music]
additional
so here i'm going to draw my signal i'm
going to call it sigma this is drawn
uniformly from the set
1 up to 2 to the power n
so it's an index it's an integer that is
drawn uniformly
and i'll observe y which is a vector
in this many dimensions
it's lambda square root n this is a
scaling that will make sense to you also
i'll talk about that more
and i'll just put this much mass and the
coordinates sigma
right
and then i'll add a gaussian
so we have a bunch of gaussians you have
a vector of size 2 to the power n
all of them are iid gaussians except one
of them that is elevated by this much
right now we observe y and i ask you to
locate the index where that has that
elevated mean right
this is a classical problem this is a
very very simple version of that problem
in statistics right
so what would you do if i give you this
problem put them here and then you have
so how to locate this guy
it's been very simple
yeah just look at the maximum
right so if i look at the maximum
coordinates and i return that as an
estimator so that's the maximum
likelihood estimator
and we can try to analyze
the performance of that estimator right
so if you look at this gaussian vector
it has size 2 to the power n right
what is the maximum entry of this of
this gaussian
vector i zi
well that concentrates very tightly
around the the quantity that we expect
so this is uh
try to make it a bit more so it's square
root 2
log the dimension
right
and that's square root 2
log 2
so you perhaps see why i put a lambda
square root n here if lambda is greater
than 2 square root 2
to log 2 excuse me
then you're going to see it
right
if it's smaller than it gets drowned in
the noise
so f
okay
mle will work
mle
works
with high probability
if and only f lambda is greater than two
log2
but this is probably okay i don't know a
priority that this is the best estimator
right so can you come up with a better
estimator
better i mean can you lower this value
and you can still succeed
if i try to do this i need to understand
the fundamental limits of this problem
and i can try to compute the free energy
so i told you if you want to compute the
mmsc you can compute the free energy
right so let's compute the free energy
so this says um
let me redefine it so i need to divide
by n in different definition
so the free energy
i'll divide by n
and then i'll take the same expression
as before
so in our particular case what is that
integral dp0 etc so i'm looking just at
a uniform prior
and i'm summing over all indices
right and i have that exponential that
shows up here square root lambda n
y times e zero
e excuse me e sigma so that gives you y
sigma
minus
i had a minus lambda over two x squared
and i told you if you're in high
dimension
you just put a 2 norm here
and x is e0 so this is 1
so i just get lambda n over 2.
the index you know the value well you
don't know the value you i'm trying to
find the index
so when you know lambda you know n you
don't under you don't observe z how
could you ever do that efficiently when
you to the end no let's say n is 10 uh
it's not uh
yeah
we're going to let n go to infinity but
this is just for for sure
i mean just call two to the power on and
call it m and then i only care about m
right so with this definition
i have the following results
so the strain energy will convert to a
function
that looks like this
if
lambda greater than 2 log
2 zero otherwise
so it looks like this
so this is lambda c which will log to
zero up here and then it's just a linear
function
so i'll prove this a bit later
it's not hard
now what can you deduce from this
i have a function that converges point
wise to another function as n goes to
infinity
i also computed the derivatives of this
the derivative of this is
i erased it
just one half
the expectation of
zero mean which is e sigma given y
right
but
okay so i computed the derivative and i
have point twice converges of this
function but if a function converges
point twice doesn't mean that the
derivative converges right
but here the function is convex it
computed the second derivative and it
was positive right
and then you can still do this now so
there is a pyramid analysis
f
f n is
of x
refreshable
and
fn converges to f point fives
then
f the limit is convex
if it's convex it'll be differentiable
almost everywhere but it's going to be
actually differentiable
everywhere except countably uncountably
many points so let's just say
differentiable almost everywhere
almost everywhere
and
f prime
of lambda will converge to f
and prime will converge to f prime
for all lambda
which
f
is differentiable
so look at all the points in which f has
a derivative then this holds
so i can try to apply this to this
now what is the derivative of the
limiting function
uh derivative of the limiting function
one half and zero
right
so this function is differentiable
everywhere except on the critical point
right
so that means that
f prime of lambda
will converge to this derivative
all
lambda not lambda c right
all right great
now we computed an expression of this
guy
well yeah
so what is the mms
mmsc
n lambda
so from the expression of the
usual information
that was the derivative of twice the
derivative
x 0 y
and i can try to write this in terms of
the free energy so we did that and we
had
uh
zero minus
so there was a two here
and there was a one half here
right
so this is one this is x is e sub sigma
so this is always normal
so we get one minus two
right
okay so now from this we can deduce what
the mms use
the msc will be now so if this is one
half
this is zero
and if this is zero this is one
so we completely characterized
the limits of estimation for this
problem
so either either you get it and maximum
likelihood will get it for you
in this regime or maximum likelihood
will not get it in which case nothing
gets it
okay so this is a phase transition and
the phase transition shows up just in
the critical point here so if you have a
so this is what the physicist aaron fess
gave as a definition of a phase
transition you look at the free energy
you look at the limit of the free energy
the thermodynamic limit of the free
energy
and if it's non-analytic at a certain
point you say that there is a phase
transition so phase transitions are
points where the the limiting function
of the free energy limit limits of
energy
is non-analytic and this is a kink here
so it's not analytic here that's the
only phase transition we have in this
problem
so the derivative of this e i
right and i is this i just replaced i
but what it is so once you're taking the
derivative
there's a lambda i always forget the
lambda
thank you
i always forget the one
other questions
so uh this is so this shows that the
face relation happens at this longer
yeah
does this mean that and you got this
same transition happening when you took
the maximum uh
actual likelihood estimate so that says
that the maximum likelihood estimate is
the best estimate exactly
yeah that's not always true in this
particular example it is correct yeah so
you're not using the concentration at
all of these zi's to their x the max
losing their expectation
so
because like if you're at exactly lambda
equals two log two then maybe like half
the time you'd be able to tell right
right so i did not look at what happens
at the critical point that's much more
difficult so you're going to have to go
into more detail you're going to have to
zoom in in the problem and look at more
details of what's happening
like let's say you're like 2 log 2 like
plus like
lambda plus like a delta that's like
really really tiny yeah same thing yeah
near critical phenomena
that's the same thing right
that's uh you know there was a field
middle this year about that kind of
thing of course not for the children
what is the model
uh used for
like for more complicated
yeah we'll see a more complicated i
don't know about how complicated you can
get so i'll try in the last lecture i'll
try to tie this with big nuts so we can
give you enough time but you can go
relatively complicated
yeah
because following up and sorry these are
like questions
around like
is there something that can look
non-analytic like this when you don't
worry about concentration at all but
then when you think about concentration
like things are actually like smooth but
very very sharp correct yeah so there
are many problems where
at this scale of the problem at scale n
of the problem you see a kink you see a
phase transition but you would like to
zoom in what's going on exactly at that
phase transition so there could be a
window where things are smooth but the
window is sublinear
so when you divide by and then shrink
out
like an example of a problem like this
so there's okay
let's talk about this often
i'm gonna go a lot uh off topic
okay
so i didn't prove okay perhaps i'll
prove this this formula and then we'll
go to the next lecture afterwards
so how do you prove this um
i want to introduce this because it's
very useful so this is either
called the moments method or
maybe just jensen's inequality in this
case
and we're going to see some interesting
phenomena that happened
so my fn f lambda
1 over n expectation logarithm
all right so that's my expression
and i want to understand what this
what's going on here i want to compute
the limits
so you can see that so there's an
expectation and a logarithm if you want
to obtain an upper bound you can use
jensen's inequality and put the
expectation inside
if i put this whole expectation inside
whatever this is this is called the
anneal free energy this is just a name
annealed free energy right let me not do
that i'm not going to put the entire
expectation inside i'm going to put a
conditional expectation inside so what
i'm going to condition on
so the randomness comes from y correct
in this in this whole thing the only
thing that is random is y
i'm going to condition on the location
of the actual mean
the actual elevation right
and the noise that is that accompanies
that right
i'm gonna condition on these two
variables
and then i use johnson so jensen
expectation of this whole thing but
given
these two guys
so what is that
okay condition on these two guys i have
still to the power n minus one terms
that are independent they don't care
about what's going on here and i can
just hit them with an expectation so if
you hit this with an expectation if this
is not
sigma zero so
this is just
this if sigma is not sigma zero
right this is a gaussian you had this so
this is the monument of the gaussian
it's one right this is normalized by
this one
so i get this times to the power n minus
one times one
and then i get the term that i did not
consider in the expectation which would
be just
lambda n
y sigma naught minus lambda n over 2.
so let me expand this guy
so i get z
sigma naught
plus
this times the same thing which is
remove the square root
right
lambda n minus lambda n over 2 and this
gives me this lambda
so let me
expand this so i get one
on this
plus this nice
let me write this as
exponential square root lambda n
plus lambda n over 2. i had a 2 to the
power minus n here i'm just going to put
it here
perhaps you see the lambda over two
minus log two which is going to show up
right so if lambda is positive
like lambda is positive
then this is positive if lambda is
greater than 2 log 2 this thing is
positive and it's uh
linear in n so this is exponentially
large
so this term will go away it just
depends on square root of n this is
linear and um so i can just ignore this
right
so i can ignore this i can ignore this
then you have
the logarithm i can ignore this the
logarithm will hit this then you have an
n and n here it's going to go away with
the n i get
this over to the next lecture
under greater than lambda c
if this is negative which means that
lambda is smaller than lambda c
this is negative so this whole thing
goes away
this goes away log of one is zero
otherwise
so in order to do this computation you
have to know what to condition on
right
and i just came up with this i didn't
tell you why i did it right
so now let's just not do this and just
push the entire expectation inside
so what do we get do we get the right
answer do we get some other answer so
let's do that
[Music]
all right so let's compute the anneal
free energy
so the annealed as i said is just uh
jensen full jensen
that whole thing
so you get the same the 2 to the power n
minus one terms are still the same when
you hit them with an expectation you get
you get one
and the next term that you're going to
have to care about is this one so i put
an expectation here right
an expectation here the only thing that
is random is z z is a gaussian
so i guess when i hit that one an
expectation i get exponential let me
remove the expression
lambda n over two
and then this is uh you can add add
stuff up like this
right
so i get an additional lambda over 2
times n that i didn't have because of
the square root here
right
so at the end i get
1 minus 2 to the power minus n
it's really the same thing right
plus exponential
lambda
n minus
n log 2.
now you see that this okay so this is
i don't have to explain too much here
this is lambda minus
log 2
if lambda greater than log 2
zero otherwise
that function is strictly uh bigger than
this one right so that function is
like this
lambda okay they don't have the same
slope this is a higher slope
so it's an upper bound that works here
but that doesn't work here
luxury
right
and so you can ask why why is this the
case when i push the expectation inside
i get the wrong answer
or it's because typically the partition
function doesn't concentrate
right so the partition function
fluctuates widely it fluctuates as an
exponential scale
typically and this is a pervasive
phenomenon in all models of statistical
physics
in the cases like it is rare that the
partition function doesn't fluctuate too
much and those are cases of very
specific interest so like we like those
cases when the partition function
doesn't fluctuate too much
now if you know that your partition
function doesn't fluctuate a lot and
then when you hit it with an expectation
it gives you the wrong answer you can
ask what is responsible for this
what events what atypical event is going
on here
that makes my partition function blow up
right and you can try to condition away
that event
so that once you condition it away you
get something that behaves well right
so i claim that that that event is this
i mean it's not an event it's a random
variable right so once i condition on
this everything becomes chain
but if i don't condition on this things
blow up right
so if you want to be a little bit more
precise with this intuition
i can consider the following sequence of
events
i'm going to index them by a parameter
tau
and my event will be just that sigma
z sub sigma 0
is greater than square root tau times n
for some tau then i'm going to choose
later right okay this is my event this
is a univariate gaussian this is
something that blows up square root n
right so this event has very small
probability yes
and then come up with something
um
yeah sorry excuse me this is just an
upper bound that tells me that this is
the exact answer you can do in lower
bound
and the lower bound i'll
just do one line
that's n of lambda
greater than what
i'll cancel out i'll forget about all of
these all of everybody in the sum
accepts these except the term that
contributes to the signal
so i'm saying one over n log
thank you only not three i completely
forgot
and i'll put a sigma zero
lambda n
sigma zero minus
from that temperature
okay if you do the computation here
you'll see that you get the same answer
let me not do it
does that answer your question
thank you
so if i consider the sequence of events
then the probability of e tau
is very small so this is a gaussian you
get the gaussians sub gaussian tail
minus tau n over 2.
so this is an exponentially small
exponentially rare event but when it
happens
it contributes in an outsized way to the
to the partition function when this
event happens it doesn't happen often
but what it does it blows up the
partition function
okay so how do you see
that excuse me
so i can before computing the expression
suppose i didn't know how to compute the
expectation of z based on this
observation i can just based on this
observation without computing anything
i can deduce that the expectation of z
cannot possibly
you know the nail free energy cannot
possibly be the the quenched free energy
so
expectation of z is always larger than
the expectation of z given
that event times the probability of that
event right
because this is positive
right
i can just lower bound it this way i
know this stats now what is the
expectation of z given this
so z is this
now this event only deals with this
random variable and the rest of them
since their iid you just hit them with
an expectation and you get this term
right
now
the only thing that's going to matter
for that computation is this right so
this is greater than 1 minus
this plus
this term but then i know that this is
large so i'll just lower bound
that conditional expectation but
whatever i lower bounded z by
square root lambda l n
plus
lambda n over two minus luxury
okay
so i'll forget about this term
i'll forget about this term so this is
exponentially large so these terms do
not matter
let's just say that you're larger than
this thing
so this is larger than exponential
so lambda tau
and
plus n times what is this function is f
star
now z is larger than
you're going to have to multiply by this
so we get exponential let me start with
this guy
okay
exponential lambda tau
square root
minus tau over 2.
okay
so the expectation of z is
what it should be
which is this is the correct answer i
mean the correct answer for z but the
great answer to the free energy times
this term so now i can choose tau to be
small enough for this to be positive
right if
tau is smaller than for lambda
lambda
then
this thin is positive
right
so it's exponentially larger
so now you see that
the expectation of z
is much much larger than
exponential
the expectation of the logarithm of c
right by a
exponentially large factor
in this in this case
so you can attribute the blow up of the
partition function to a particular
family of events which is this one
and turns out that if you condition them
away then
you get equality if you condition the
stuff away if you condition the right
thing right
which i did there
better questions here so this happens
all the time this happens for instance
in random sats it happens in spring
glass models in low temperature it
happens even in high temperature for
models that are not symmetric it happens
all the time
so this is a pervasive phenomenon
so the point of this was to show you
that you're gonna have to understand the
properties of your model if you're
trying to compute the free energy if the
expectation of z just blows up
you're gonna have to really understand
what's going on in order to make things
work and you
not we don't know how to do that always
how much time do i have
okay almost
other questions
perhaps this is a natural way to start a
natural point to stop
let me tell you what i'm going to talk
about next in the next lecture i'll go
to the
one model that is slightly more involved
which is the spike structure model
so this is the model where you observe a
matrix now
and
the signal vector it's not a vector
anymore it's a random matrix and you add
gaussian a gaussian matrix to it
and you can try to ask the same
questions can i compute the free energy
what is the limits the fundamental
limits of estimating the spike this is
called the spike
and uh we're gonna see some tools more
tools and then we're gonna ask about
algorithms how do you figure out what
the spike is once you know that it is
possible to estimate it what can you do
so i'll talk about
amp okay
so i'll stop here thank you
i